[Music]
next we go to raleigh north carolina rob
is there rob how can we help
good afternoon gentlemen happy friday
happy friday to you sir what's up
uh so i have an uh interesting question
for you guys i i am uh in baby steps
four five and six with our with our
family great and i know that i know the
position that you all take with respect
to
leasing vehicles
and i'm not going to try to set any new
precedent today but i do have a question
on the lease idea when it comes to
horses
my wife is
really into horses and so are my kids
when you're in baby step two you don't
get to enjoy that type of thing but now
we're in four five and six
they would like to
get a horse or or two
and uh apparently it's become popular
this in today's time to actually lease
a horse so that basically you have the
monthly payments and the upkeep but you
don't have to worry about well i guess
it depends on your contract but you
don't have to worry about getting rid of
it at the end of the day okay hold on a
second all right hold on hold on i gotta
know more because this might shock you i
know nothing about leasing horses uh is
this like a boat thing where multiple
people are using the same boat multiple
multiple people using the same horse you
get you get larry the horse monday
wednesday friday i mean what's the deal
it is not a time share
it is uh you're actually uh you got all
so you it's only you and your family and
larry nobody else rides larry
that's it so you're just renting a horse
essentially wow
basically yeah okay well why would you
why would you why would you think i
distinguished that
the reason i distinguished that from a
vehicle right is because of the vehicle
at the end of the day you can take it to
another you know dealership and you know
they might give you cash for it a horse
is much more difficult to get rid of
yeah you know
do you know what happens to poor larry
the horse when we get rid of him it's
awful
i don't think you can say that live i
know i'm not planning to two things
everybody knows just because it's
popular doesn't mean it's not a terrible
idea eating tide pods became popular
doesn't mean we should all start doing
it
no so leasing a horse is no different a
horrible idea if you can't pay cash for
it you can't afford a horse how much
does it cost to buy a horse
no i don't think the issue is paying
cash for it i think the issue is once
you know if you need to up and leave if
you need to move you can sell the horse
you can't
okay
i mean i guess you could i guess you're
assuming that there are willing buyers
out there you're a willing buyer can i
remind you that you are willing to buy a
horse rob thought he got me there in the
corner do you not think there's other
robs out there who may want a horse yeah
who have little girls that want to ride
a horse i wouldn't plan on it being an
appreciating asset well you got to look
at this thing as a liability it's an
expense this is a hobby but if you guys
are debt-free and you want to pay cash
for a horse and deal with all the
maintenance because this is a dream of
yours i'm okay with that okay
but do not fall for this horse leasing
business it's just awful
i mean rob you're a good guy you're in
baby steps four or five and six like you
didn't think we were gonna be cool with
this did you
i didn't but it just seems different
than a vehicle i mean it's just so rough
justification station here you're
looking for any reason to get this horse
at any cost i i got i got a little
comeback rob there was a time in the
world where horses were the only
vehicles
rob quit horsing around let's pay cash
for this there it is folks i was
wondering if you were gonna say that i
was there george campbell for the win
everybody
here to save the day james would it have
killed you to pull up a horse sound to
take us out somebody in the booth's got
to be thinking there's a reason they
don't let us use sound effects on the
show uh very good all right hey rob baby
steps four five and six does not include
leasing a horse this is the ramsay show